hi everyone it's claire and today we are
unboxing the bunny playfulness blind box
set from popmart they have two designs
on the box and there's some secret
designs that we could possibly find in
this one so let's get into it
[Music]
let's take a look and see what's inside
let's go
yo
i'm gonna cut this very carefully
it's so cute
i really love the color palette that
they chose i think it really fits the
name
let's go
[Applause]
okay so we have a total of 12 blind
boxes in here oh
there's exactly 12 and there's 12 um
designs on the box at the bottom
not secret ones see
where should we start away i'm going to
start from see bottom right oh this that
oh it's that quick
see oh okay i really like this tricycle
design here the one in the top left i'm
sure you can see oh there you go
you say use the scissors but i'm going
to rip it open with my bare hands i'm so
sorry
okay
first one
oh i said another blind bag okay so
you have a little stand
for
the collectible
and
a toy
queen
oh
this is
the card of the toy that we're going to
see sheltering from the rain it's kind
of cute
okay oh yeah also mention that it's
about the whole set is about you know
like a reminiscent of like childhood
anything oh
okay
so this bunny playfulness that is
actually about reminiscing childhood
memories so i think maybe
inside is that sheltering reindeer let's
see
oh
i can do it for a lot for us
oh it is
[Applause]
it's so cute it's a little leaf and like
a raindrop
i love the hair
it's so pink
i like the contrast between the pink and
the green
cute look
so cute okay this one
okay second one
see who we
get okay i'm not gonna take out the name
card this time since it's all spoiled it
for us
please
oh yeah oh what's this
so cute she has bunny ears oh
little hat let's see
what is your name
oh
bunny playfulness building blocks oh
does she have building blocks inside oh
my gosh wait
oh she does
this little chair
okay
let's move everything over to the side
put your name first down
so i think she sits on it
like this
oh no it's the other way around okay it
is
that's adorable
little rabbit growing blocks
okay
it's our second one okay
exciting
next one
oh
you have a butterfly net oh i guess this
is some spoiler already see you guys
yeah
now she looks like oh oh my gosh she has
a butterfly on her face
that's so cute
she missed it but she got it on her face
she got backpack for all her butterflies
i wonder what she has in there
there she is
oh i just realized they have different
icons for each doll
oh
that's interesting okay
put
the net in her hand
let's go
no repeats no repeats no repeats no
repeats no repeats no peace
yeah i feel like i should be more gentle
with this but i can drink it so hard
okay okay okay
okay
see we get
oh
who's this
check your name card
huh
what
bunny playfulness she's catching fish
oh so the little circle that we got it's
a pond oh okay that makes more sense
i think this one is my favorite so far
she's holding little fish and she has a
fishbone
adorable okay pulls her like this
blind bag out it's really
crunchy
let's feel for the shape
oh
i think it's in a different pose this
time
rather than standing up let's have
someone
oh she's standing up but what's that oh
my gosh is this a swing boy oh
who is this
learning to swim oh it's so cute she has
a little
swan hat as well for her ears
[Applause]
[Music]
oh she has really cute pink tights
cute balloon with a duck on it
okay
let's see what's your name
tricycle oh wait yes this is the one i
wanted there's a tricycle in here
let's put it on it
i think this is one of the
few blind boxes that i've seen come with
like a lot of extra accessories
like
it's so cool it's actually okay it's not
exactly a tricycle it looks like
it looks like more like a
little scooter it's really flat at the
bottom
anyways pitch fit
oh
chief is okay little hands resting on
the handles
she's so cute look at her hat
is that's my favorite
okay
next okay
now that i've got we've got inside and
like
see where they're gonna give us any
secret ones
see who's inside
oh this is the candle girl
oh okay so she's called orange light oh
she has little green ears though it's
really cute
okay i think they have a specific name
for these like uh
oh oh no it's not a teacup it's like an
orange slice it's not a handle but it's
so cute and it's little leaves at the
bottom
put her in yay
oh my gosh
you see the orange slice
okay so we've rearranged our setup a
little bit to make more space for our
bunnies honestly we've like have
completed our army of bunnies here so
let's
increase your doubles let's go
our eighth body
being really lucky no repeats hope that
stays that way
okay okay
the accessories are gonna come out and
we're going to get spoiled oh no
can i go back in go back in nobody look
okay
i'm back
even though i saw the accessories i
still have no idea who's going to come
out this bag let's
take a look
always at first i think it's quite funny
oh
lavender
she looks a little bit like a
circus ballerina she's so cute lavender
this is the leotard yeah
i think she's the oh one of the few
bunnies with
like downward facing but upward ears on
the top
okay let's see what her accessories are
oh it's a little slide that's cute okay
let's put her on her slide before we see
that chance
oh
no
okay
see what your name is
your name is slide okay i think that's
pretty straightforward
it's a pretty key childhood memory for a
lot of people
um i think playgrounds were pretty
accessible to me when i was younger so i
do remember
being in this position a lot
i hope she doesn't fall
oh no
okay there she is
so we're down to our final four boxes
almost done
honestly oh no our tab okay
i'm going to have to try it open with my
hands
i'm going to rip it open with my bare
it's bunny roughness
oh that's great
oh
oh it's another butterfly girl
oh well that's our first repeat which is
really cute i forgive her next one no
repeats no repeats please no please
maybe a secret
secret design
maybe
oh
oh wow
this one's actually like really solid
it doesn't feel like a doll inside this
is really our secret design oh my gosh
oh but maybe she's oh i think i know who
this is okay let's let's open up
there she's oh my gosh she's so cute
little multi-colored bubbles bubbles
wait bubbles
and she have oh she has little bubble
toys this is so scary
oh yes she has a little bubble toy with
her in the bag okay i'll open it up and
give it to her
bubble blowing toy okay i do remember
this quite vividly
i still like to blow bubbles now and
then
it's such a
like randomly fun activity i wonder who
made it up
there she is
oh
and her dress has little frills too
cute
and her bow reminds me of snow white
quite a bit okay
let's go
oh
oh oh no she's trapped in your own
bubble
oh
no
that i feel like that unlocks a new fear
for me to be trapped in a bubble i mean
you can just like force your way out of
it
but that's a little bit horrifying
okay there she is
okay we're down to our second last box
who is it gonna be
okay we're still missing two designs
um
maybe
i dare say three because we haven't seen
our secret design yet
a repetition who could it be
oh okay
oh it's a series on top this time
crunchy
[Applause]
is this shape new it's like a sort of
dome shape in here
but it's not as big of a dome as the
bubble girl
hmm
who is this
maybe it is purple girl maybe i'm
mistaken
oh it's not it's not but
[Applause]
what is this
oh cookie blanket oh she's so cute this
is the commercial body and then
the blanket has stucky and banana prints
on
it that's so adorable
she doesn't come with any
stand she looks just so cute there she
is i wish they put like a rubber duck
toy with her
half half wish so cute
so we're down to our last box no
okay
i'm missing we are missing catching ants
and the secret design let's see where do
we get it
which one could it be repeat either
which one which one is it
i'm dying to find out
it's just dead it's just the sand oh
oh we have a magnifying glass i guess we
know who it is
let's open her up
[Applause]
oh
there she is the catching ends bunny
doll
oh she's dressed i wonder what's this
headpiece i think it's quite cute
give her
a little magnifying glass
i'm surprised there's no ant accessory
honestly i think like a huge ant would
be cute
and interesting oh
there she is catching hands
and that is our final doll i hope this
stand fits on her leg it does not
sadness
so i've had a lot of fun opening up all
these blind boxes today i kind of said
that we got a repeat of this butterfly
catcher she's so cute look at her i
think that popmart did a great job with
this concept of bunny playfulness and
childhood reminiscence and i really
enjoyed myself today so that's all for
this video remember to follow us on all
our socials like subscribe if you
haven't and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you